what's up everyone i'm jordan may and
i'm joined by patrick mattei creative
director for rainbow six
i was about to say siege rainbow six
extraction thank you for joining me
today
it's a pleasure so you could tell i i've
been playing siege like since day one
i've put in a lot of
hours so and i'm like i'm really excited
to
talk about extraction with you because
i'm like oh yes new new rainbow six game
but like if i accidentally say like
siege when i'm supposed to be saying
extraction please just
bear with me i'll i'll do my best
no problem at all i'm doing i i i did it
myself
a few times so it's okay okay that makes
that makes me feel so much better
so so now obviously like extraction
shares some dna with siege like
that's probably why sometimes i get a
little mixed up in my mind and i kind of
want to
pick your brain about that specifically
so
starting off a rainbow six siege has a
lot of operators it launched with just a
few but now there's just this
massive roster of different characters
that people are able to choose from
so how did you pick which ones would
make the jump from
siege to extraction but like you said a
huge
amount of operators available in siege
so for us it was very
very fun and also challenging
to take a look at the the roster and
decide which one
we would bring uh with us uh in uh
in extraction uh i would say there's too
many
too many uh points that we took for sure
uh
the gameplay aspect of each operator
some operators are
a best fit for a pve experience
so we we picked those operators but we
also
chose a few operators either because we
knew that they were
really loved by the community and in
some cases i would even go as far as to
say
we pick some of the operators that maybe
didn't receive as much love
as as we would have liked uh in siege
but that we think that it can shine uh
in a context like extraction because it
was one of those things that uh
aaron who at gamespot checked out uh
extraction ahead he came back from the
preview like my first question for him
was like
isabana still there is my girl still
there is my mane
still in the cave
so siege and extraction are these two
different games so how does
in-game progress work in extraction does
it work
off of siege where if you've unlocked
certain operators in siege 11 lock them
in extraction is it a totally different
process do the two games feed into each
other
how does that work obviously both games
are
built on the same foundations but
they're
two different games it's really
extraction is a standalone game
with its own ecosystem so there's no
direct link
in terms of progression between
extraction
and siege what you do in extraction you
will get the gain
inside extraction i'm gonna have to
probably unlock habana again is what
you're saying
uh probably
well i'll i'll do it i'll put in the
hours i'll get my girl back
and i guess kind of like almost jumping
off of that why the decision
to make that clean break away from siege
as opposed to just
bringing outbreak back as like a more
permanent mode like you've decided to
now go in this completely
different pve direction with a separate
game
what's the reasoning behind that there
there's uh
two uh two different elements that uh
that brought us to this place uh first
off uh is the
outbreak event like you know a few years
ago there was an event
in siege where it was a pve event that
lasted three weeks
uh the reception was very good the
community really
loved it and on the other side
at ubisoft montreal were big studios
there's a lot of different projects
going on and there was
always this uh discussions about doing a
pve game
uh so it was like a bit like the stars
were allowing
to look at okay could we take uh
the foundation of siege and come up with
a standalone game
to really push the envelope in terms of
a a real
tactical co-op game and that's what we
did
and now that extraction is coming out as
this
completely separate game will sieges
like future updates influence
extraction like if a new operator is
coming to see just there a possibility
that it comes to extraction or
now the two games kind of like will they
diverge and go down two
completely separate paths it's too soon
to say
uh the only thing uh i can set this
point though
and you entered at it uh in the
beginning
uh when siege came onto the market it
started with a limited amount of
operators
and it grew a lot from there
so i can not tell more at this time
but we have certainly different plans
already in place
for the very near future the teas the
teas you have my mind erasing at the
possibility of maybe getting like brand
new operators and extraction
possibly even unique operators i uh
i know you're limited i know that you
can't speak to it i
will have to do another article on the
line
yeah they just they have their finger
over the button it's like we'll cancel
this interview right here right now
don't test us but uh let
let's talk story a little bit like so
what is the goal
of that team rainbow's trying to
accomplish in extraction
um so in terms of the context uh
three years ago they were the operators
were facing
an outbreak and at the time they thought
that they dealt
with the threat and it was over in
extraction
uh they will very quickly and very
abruptly realize that the threat
is not only not over but it evolved
it's not the same threat anymore and uh
and a bit like uh like the situation
worldwide situation that we lived in the
last
year uh they don't know much about this
new threat
so as a an operator you are going in
incursion
to go there and not necessarily to
to fight or to kill uh the enemy
but really to go and gather as much
knowledge as you can
on this unknown threat
and that way the react team the react
scientific
can analyze it and give you
better tool to fight and
uh fight detroit i'm saying how exactly
will extraction tell its story is it
just the traditional cut scenes is it
like environmental world building
storytelling where people have to find
clues during the levels what's the
what's the deal yeah i
i would say it's a mix of uh different
things uh
for sure at the core the game uh once
again
it's a tactical uh co-op shooter so we
didn't want to put
uh too much uh constraint and to to
force the players to
to listen to very long cutscenes we know
some players love it
uh some players have less interest for
that
so we made sure that yes there's going
to be a few cutscenes
uh you'll you'll have a lot of
interaction
with uh the antlers or the the
the people that stay behind and that
gives you intel about
what's going on uh and also about what
you should do
or not and we also have what we call the
codex
which is basically all the knowledge
that you will gather
uh while doing the objectives will go
in the cadets so for the players that
are very interested
in understanding a bit more about the
lore and the mysteries
of the threat the parasite where it's
coming from what it wants
uh it will all all be stored
in the codex and like you've hinted we
have a bunch of
easter eggs uh hidden inside the
different maps
so you might have the time uh to find
some although
be careful the game is quite challenging
so uh
it's yeah it's gonna be a mix
of man i know that there's probably like
a secret in here that i really want to
find at the same time
oh my friend is dying i need to go back
and say that
exactly and if
a few days ago i had a
questions like i like that and i was not
necessarily uh
aware of all the the easter egg that
were in the in the maps
so i asked around and i ended up having
the full uh
the full list and i was blown away
because i've been playing the game for
quite a while now and i would say i i
i found maybe 10 of them the 98 other
percent i was not even aware
it was in the game and some of them are
quite impressive
okay cool cool like as as an aside when
pr is not watching anymore just like
pass me the list and we we can discuss
like
lower secrets and stuff like that
afterwards
like like i uh i like to say every man
as it surprised
so let's talk
[Music]
so in your own experience uh playing
extraction like you've
mentioned already that there's like it's
still a bit of a tactical experience but
how
does it if in any way like compare to
siege like is it the same like
really tactical experience is it a bit
more arcadey does it play
pretty much exactly the same what's the
comparison
i know it doesn't play at all the same
uh just the nature of it
having a only five opponents but five
opponents that are human in front of you
is not the same as
uh as being in a pv environment but i
i would say that the best me the biggest
difference is
if you compare uh extraction to
what i would call a other run and gun uh
horde mode shooter out there this is
certainly something we didn't want to do
there's great games that accomplish it
but on our side it was really
a matter of making sure that you feel
like you're a
swat team and you're for sure you're
outnumbered
but if you go gun blazing uh you won't
have the level of success
that you might think you could have it's
really a matter of surprising the enemy
uh being ready to retreat quickly
if things go go goes badly
and not go in an entrenched war
against the enemy because it's not gonna
be a recipe for success for sure
and could someone theoretically
pick this game up and try to play
through it completely on their own like
is there an
offline version of this game or is this
like
nah you should probably find some
friends online to play with
i would say uh for sure you can play the
game from a to z
in single player and it's very
interesting
it's the same game it's not something
different it's not a different mode it's
the same game
but the the the feel and the
the the tension is not the same
because when you play alone uh you are
much more in control obviously because
there's no one
making mistakes apart from you
but at the same time if things go badly
it's going to be much tougher but we
have
to the game at its core when we started
working in the game right from the
get-go we wanted to make
a co-op game where three players would
help each other
to achieve the best level of success and
and at the same time allowing player to
play alone or with a friend
so that because uh on my side
it happens often i play with my friends
every week but there's always one of
them
that is late uh so that way you can
still play and it's the same
like i said it's not different game mode
so it's the same progression
so you can still uh continue to play and
the progress that you'll make playing
alone
will translate uh in your three players
quiet and vice versa
well unfortunately that's kind of
all the time that we have so thank you
again
patrick it was awesome to talk to you
about extraction i'm very proud of
myself calling it
extraction for this entire interview and
not mistakingly referring to it as siege
as i
originally thought that i would for
those of you watching at home
remember stay safe out there and for
more on rainbow six siege rainbow six
extraction
and play for all content stay tuned to
gamespot
you